good afternoon rules committee
for Monday April twenty ninth
a call to order please advise
on audio video recorded for
these procedures be Mayes
as also being televised
on Mister secretary please
call the roll Cooley here
Cunningham Carillo flora
Grayson Kamlager-Dove
Maienschein Mathis quirk Silva
Ramos here leave us here
Wicks we have a quorum
we have consent agenda is are
emotionally consent move there
moved by several roles
-- Mister sector please call
the roll Cooley hi who we
aye Cunningham Cunningham
high Carillo hi flora
aye flora aye aye Grayson
Grayson I'd Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove I am Maienschein
Mathis hi Mathis hi quirk Silva
Ramos almost I request
previous five weeks hi Wicks hi
the motion is passed and this
rules because thank you very